story though where you been i've been in
boston i had a great time when you come
back with the flu not the flu i have a
little
[ __ ] plane in the back oh my god
and god knows what collaborates back
there what what what role were you with
26 jesus christ almighty how did you end
up back there because what do you get
when you fly in america [ __ ] people i
don't know nobody you know people give
me some miles i don't know but i got god
yeah yesterday was bad because the
flight coming in from chicago was
delayed a little bit and then the plane
was like from 1987 it was it was like
super old but i had a great time cross
country flight oh god yeah super old
flight yeah and it didn't happen like
none of the none of the monitors it
still the flip down screens whatever i
actually had
i haven't been back to boston since a
year ago last may so it was just great i
hadn't seen my mom for
almost nine months so it was a good time
to go home you went to the museum yeah
we saw the pixar exhibit which was fun
we went to fenway and i i started i
almost started sobbing i had to hold it
together because my mom was there
because i had my mom on my on my podcast
and she told a story when they thought i
had cancer as a little kid and luckily i
didn't
and then the kid who threw out the first
pitch at fenway was like the
six-year-old was born premature just
like me
and had beaten cancer and he's walking
out in the entire
the thing i love about boston and the
thing that bothers me about dodgers and
i i know when they have big games they
go out but for small games when they're
not doing that while i've been there it
hasn't been that great of an experience
at dodger stadium fenway we're 10 games
under 500 the place is packed and
40 000 people are cheering for the
six-year-old and i'm just i'm just
bawling he threw a strike from from the
from the pitcher's mound it was just uh
it was i i missed boston sometimes
so you had a good time with the family
hell yeah
he went to legals got some chowder what
else did g the wig was telling fried
shrimp chowder and then what else
chowder yeah uh that's it i got a caesar
salad too caesar salad look at you
living like a shrimp chicken not on the
salad no that's the remedy
yeah i don't mess with stuff on the
salad it's weird beautiful what about
you do you have a good weekend i had a
nice weekend with the family went
swimming did the whole [ __ ] uh kid
thing what are you going to do called
turley what's happening how you doing
it's good to be here what's going on man
everything all right yeah and
everything's great before the podcast
we're talking about billionaires school
started school started
first [ __ ] back oh yeah yeah man
traffic is back people are stuck they
don't know how to make the left
but it's funny we're talking about
billionaires before the show started
what what do you do
i mean when you have 11 what what were
they worth between combined like because
the the owner the owners the owner
himself owns like every sports team in
colorado he owns the rams and then he
owns a one of those european soccer
teams or football teams so he is like
almost seven and his wife is the heiress
to the walmart fortune so right now on
wikipedia it says almost five so it's
like close to 11 or 12 combined what
what do you do when you got five billion
you just i would go to the bank whatever
the [ __ ] you want let's say the bank
opens at nine i'm there at 9-0-1 you
never go to the bank i go to the
drive-through window the bank comes to
you and the bank goes beep and i go [ __ ]
you and i drive away that's what i do
9-0-1 every day just go to the bank and
say [ __ ] you yeah i own this
[ __ ]
yeah pretty much that's pretty much 4.8
billion they own banks i never dreamed
of having money like that i wouldn't
know how to act
i wouldn't know how to [ __ ] behave
myself now i do but not 20 years ago
when you're a college student somebody
hands you a 14 million dollar signing
bonus or whatever the [ __ ] they do but
that shows how i got that that shows how
much like
everyone always says like sports
athletes are overpaid
but if if the owners have that much
money it shows you how much
they're like they're really not making
that much comparatively when you think
about it at the end of the day yeah at
the end of the day
like you you've said it a bunch where
like the ufc is like oh we're doing a
great thing every once a weekend but
your college football brings in
sellouts
every week 40 weeks 40 times a week 40
times a saturday alabama has a 25
million dollar surplus
they just bought nick saban's house for
them just because like last year like
you have a college that has a 25 million
dollar surplus that's just one school
and
they talk about cutting kids tuitions
and
we can't staff teachers and
the ncaa is a racket they're making i
mean you got 32 nfl football teams right
and they're worth a billion dollars a
piece roughly
how many ncaa colleges are all the cars
the whole sec is each team is worth
almost a billion
because they control the whole state
what was it like for you as a college
player like
with like that was that shitty that was
in san diego state yeah well they had
that basketball player who did who was
like on the national championship team
and said he couldn't afford food and and
yeah oh yeah yeah you got to work man i
mean i i was a kid i was one of five
kids uh my dad was a truck driver there
was no
money and there was no i wasn't going to
college if it wasn't for football
you know so going to school was uh
was was challenging as a student athlete
because of the demand you know the other
students
they they see their you get to you get a
free school this out of the other but
you're you're full-time for them you're
pretty much a slave for them i mean you
are
you're up and if if you're not a class
on time you're running if you aren't
eating you're you're running if you're
not making weight if you're not doing
this doing that making practices you
know your life is controlled so you are
a hundred percent owned by them your off
season is the only time that you can
have a job
as a college athlete you can't have a
job so you can't have any money so
you're i mean
you know try to be offensive lineman
putting on weight and all that stuff you
know it takes money you got to buy extra
food that meal ticket doesn't cover
you know four steaks a day
you know
20 chicken breasts you know that doesn't
get covered on your your meal card so
it puts guys in a bind in a big way
that's why you got jameis winston
stealing crab legs he's won the heisman
trophy you know he's made a billion
dollars for the school or whatever i'm
you know i don't know how many millions
but may as well be they were flying him
on a private jet i think between
football and baseball because he wanted
to do both right you know he's flying on
private jets he sees his coach i mean we
had a coach at san diego state that uh
just left and went to
michigan a few years ago brady hoke
and uh you know had two good years
brought the san diego state aztecs up to
another you know uh height of
recognition where we were at you know we
came off of marshall faulk years then we
had our years we broke marshall fox
records big time receiving core uh
number one offense in the country
uh all the guys on our offensive line
played the nfl etc um and then what kind
of got lost and then this coach comes
back he brings the program back up he's
here for like two years and then he gets
you know michigan comes in on a private
jet picks him up gives them a big
multi-million dollar deal san diego
state can't match it you know because
they don't put any money into football
they only put into basketball
and they take him away and he goes you
know and the players see that they see
how can't i just go get a
pair of shorts from somebody
you know or trade my shorts for a tattoo
and you get to be here and make millions
of dollars and then
you're you're not contractually i can't
just
get up and go to another school if i
don't like it here i have to sit out for
a whole year you know miss a whole year
of ball but you these coaches they float
around this whole livestock's floated
around so what do these kids have to uh
to look at and you know these are the
examples you know it's like chris carter
and tom get a fall guy it's like they
perpetuate that whole thing
and you know the owners and
oh now chris carter surprised oh i i i
didn't see until realized until just now
when i watched it it's been up on the
nfl's [ __ ] website
he's watched it before you know this is
a perpetuated mentality man
and these kids you know get in trouble
for it man it's weird what
when you're growing up and you're
watching college football
for me it was college basketball and
college football and pro everything
and you watch this and as a kid you're
like [ __ ] i could do this
i can just go to school take a few
classes
you know lift some weights and go to
college and [ __ ]
and then you
realize there's so much more involved
like there's so much more
that you have to you just don't show up
there's paperwork and this and that test
and you know you have to do this and get
sit with this guy once a week and
you don't get to go to college you know
kids get to go to college and you know
they get upset because they have to work
this and the other but they can go to
parties they can have fun
you have to commit if you don't if you
want to keep that scholarship and you
want to you know get to where you're
trying to go which is the national
football league you've got to fully
commit you got to give up spring breaks
you got to give up everything i mean you
got to train constantly that's your job
you have a job and it is full time if
you are dedicated to it you're one of
the best and you can you want to honor
that scholarship that's a full-time gig
and uh being a student athlete was was
rough i mean and then you know and then
there's the really stupid things like we
just talked about i mean i had to pay
back my last semester of my scholarship
because i signed up for all my classes
credit no credit instead of getting uh
grades and i had switched my major
mid-career so
i was able to
pick a bunch of courses that i hadn't
taken yet that were all kind of general
education type of classes and uh i could
take them credit no credit so you know i
go on test days and uh like every other
student does you know and i just show up
and i'd you know fail i'm sure because
i'm i mean these are classes of science
and english and all these you know where
you're reading books you got to really
study and i'm just like i got to focus
i'm i committed to staying at the school
i could have came out my junior year i
committed to you know stay and and try
to become a better player and get
drafted higher and represent the school
i did got drafted seventh pick overall
seventh pick yeah first round yeah
seventeen san diego state
offensive lineman
i beat out all the secs all the big ten
you know
it was crazy man
and they made me pay back my scholarship
because i i only went on test days and
the days i thought
you know got everybody else away with it
you know and i just take them no credit
so then i it wouldn't count against my
they they try to screw me over i got a
letter in the mail like you know you owe
us twenty thousand dollars you know like
okay
all right then so the day you get
drafted yeah the [ __ ] blue ink ain't
even dry on this yeah
and the red the school the school the
first one one of the first bills i got
once i got drafted and
made into national football he was from
san diego state university for twenty
thousand dollars it was the second
columbia yeah
that's the second bill that comes right
well then parking tickets is what it was
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah the city is the
city of san diego we need all that
parking money
jesus christ
seventh overall that is just uh yeah
were you were you in the like madison
square garden or wherever they held it
uh no it wasn't as big of a deal as it
is now you know it's really
commercialized now what year was this
298 98.
so still tagliabue and uh
it was just starting to get a little
silly you know with the media but it
wasn't as big a deal so i just stayed
out moreno valley out where i grew up in
the valley out there in the desert man
and i had a party at my mom's house and
the cul-de-sac invited everybody over
that's a great [ __ ] way to do it nice
and simple yeah so now you go to
you got drafted by who
new orleans yep mike ditka and then you
went there
you got traded immediately no no i got
uh i got drafted uh by coach dicka to
new orleans was there for five years and
then they traded me to st louis yeah
unfortunately mickey loomis traded me
and uh you know that was how it was
what'd you think of the saints when you
were down there
that's my that's my team man that's
i got fleur de lis all over me that's a
special place
still holds a special place in my heart
i haven't set foot in the in the
superdome
uh since i left i've had plenty
opportunities and made a lot of excuses
to get around it
and out of a lot of invitations just
because it means
it means a lot man that was a pretty
pretty special place to be in new
orleans you've been there and uh
anybody who's gone there and experienced
that city you know can attest to that
it's just a different different place
were you there during katrina uh i went
after katrina um i was not on the team i
was in st louis i just got traded uh
i was down
i was after 2003 season
and then uh i was down in mexico at the
time i had a house down there and uh
we uh saw the storm coming on the radar
on the tv and it tore up the city and so
we flew back early and uh loaded up a
truck of
supplies and stuff i raised a bunch of
money and cleared out a sam's club and
hauled it down in the 18-wheeler my dad
was a truck driver
and uh
drove it from st louis all the way down
to new orleans for the cops and the
firemen because all those guys are my
buddies and
uh i knew they were
i couldn't get a hold of any of them the
phones were all down everything was down
and so uh
we drove that truck down got in and they
waved us right on through and uh we
spent about a week down there helping
clean up and all that the team was in
san antonio
at the time they
moved away
all right
okay sorry about that
the katrina was [ __ ] crazy wasn't it
like it was crook it was nuts my friends
were down there either shooting a movie
or had just finished and they did all
this stuff
and they went back after the hurricane
and they shot
where they were shooting like the dock
with a headshot gone yeah like nothing
was left yeah and now it's ten years i
think abc's doing something special this
weekend about the ten year anniversary
of katrina and whatnot you know what i
could put you're a
no he's always kicking over something
he's not just hitting the button when
the music's on
he ain't even [ __ ] high yet he's all
you know he's straight yet he's doing
[ __ ] he's just
i've seen you [ __ ] do your thing you
just never nobody ever forced you no
more
what does it like to be traded man that
must be that's kind of crazy when you
think about like you can just send you
somewhere else no were you on the
trading block did you know you were
gonna get traded here's this team you
love yes and well with them uh i had
another year on my contract
but uh
they had just fired like they were in
talks with my agent uh about renewing my
contract extending it making me a save
for life
uh but it was re randy mueller who was
the general manager and uh randy mueller
all of a sudden after like my agent's
telling me the deal's done you know
we're gonna lock this up before the
season starts
and
you'll be the same for life
cool you know i'm not asking for
anything more than what i deserve
should be a no-brainer you know i proved
myself to the team
and then out of nowhere he gets fired
like one day he calls me up and he says
kyle you know tom benson he's he's
senile or something he's like i don't
i don't i i don't understand it
something
and i got he just fired me you know and
i'm like what
you know this is the general manager and
he would he'd only been there for like a
year or two years and we'd won like we
were winning it was a
a great team and uh
fired and he called me and then all of a
sudden the guy that was in the back room
mickey loomis who is now this big famous
guy was just crunching numbers he was
the numbers guy for them for randy
mueller's crew when they were in seattle
and running a show up there and uh he
came to new orleans it was just
crunching numbers he was the guy that
you sat down with when they redid the
contract or whatever and worked out all
your numbers um
and then he became the general manager
so
you know the owner at the time uh you
know pre-super bowl pre all the the new
money that he's got
uh
i guess was you know stretched pretty
thin so he he was
uh not one to spend the money to and and
that general manager mickey loomis was
you know set on
uh i guess making a statement with with
me i guess contractually uh as to what
kind of general manager he was gonna be
you know so a lot of things just got
started slinging around and he was you
know talking a bunch of [ __ ] about me
behind my back to my agent and my agent
was like okay you're not gonna believe
what he said
i'm like you shouldn't be telling me
this because now i'm just pissed you
know
and uh i remember after a game one time
and he came in the locker room and we
had just beaten somebody uh and it was a
big win and he came in and he said uh
he's shaking everybody's hands coming
around and you know he's just been
hearing all this stuff he's talking to
my agent about now because now the
contract you know wasn't that was done
it's not done no more anymore
and so you know now i'm sitting here
kind of got to wait and see and feel out
this new guy uh what he's
intended for me
and uh he's coming around the locker
room and great game great and i turn
around don't get the [ __ ] out of my face
man you're i don't don't act like you're
my friend
you know i thought we were cool
yeah i guess we're not
you said some [ __ ] that i don't
appreciate
you know so keep on [ __ ] down the
line telling all these guys you're
you know
congratulations because i don't want to
hear it from you
and then that just kind of snowballed
into a uh
you know
a lot of different things they're
talking about giving and their the owner
now is in some big tiff with his
granddaughter who at the time he was
talking about you know grooming her up
rita to be this uh
new owner she's gonna take over
you know and it was just like i knew
five dudes on the team that she'd been
with you know i mean making out with
married dudes and
on retreats and [ __ ] you know guys from
the team and stuff like this [ __ ] was
[ __ ]
and uh and i was just like
and then they started trading everybody
away trade willie rofoway traded uh
chris naioli away started trading
everybody away you know like what are
you guys doing you know and i was like
and now you're going to start talking
[ __ ] about me i've been
i might have i might have given it you
know
yeah you know sorry if if you would have
treated me well but i'm sorry you didn't
and
and it was a situation where i just kind
of felt like hey you guys don't want me
there then [ __ ] trade me okay i'm
tired of dealing with this [ __ ] i
don't need this i don't need you coming
back and forth about me and talking this
about me i've given everything i've had
to this organization
and then some
and it's on film you know whatever the
[ __ ] you think you've done for this team
you can go [ __ ] yourself
and uh
agent called me when i was over in some
union meetings in hawaii
and said hey kt they want to trade you
to the rams i said fine [ __ ] them
how were the rams how long were you
there for
that was uh
it would have been a good situation had
i not gotten injured man blew my back
out
and that was uh
at the same time i i could have made it
back with them had they given me uh a
proper chance
it was a it was a serious injury surgery
was involved the whole deal
and you know as an injury really took me
down you know so i was
had one great year
made all pro you know my first year
there
and
represented what i could do for the team
unfortunately suffered an injury
they contributed to
heavily in neglect you know i was
complaining of things that uh were
telltale signs of that something's going
on with my back you know they're all the
sciatica nerves and all that stuff you
know
uh
and they were just they'll just shoot
you up you know shoot you up with all
these drugs with toradol and and
cortisone you know numb it and uh it's
something in your hip it's no big deal
you know we'll see it after the season's
over with after the season comes so
oh wow you've got a herniated disc the
size of a [ __ ] golf ball
oh that's why you can't get out of bed
now and that's why it's starting to
seize up now after the season's over
with because your body you know you're
not moving around like you were you're
not working out like you were now all of
a sudden you take you know you're
relaxing and laying down from trying to
take you take a load off for a few weeks
and all of a sudden you get out of bed
wrong one day and there it goes all the
way you know
and uh
you know it could have been resolved
probably with some rest and take a
couple games off you know or treatment
and uh
it wouldn't have been as severe as it
was you know probably never would even
had to face surgery but
you know that's the way they ran the
show
and then i got involved with the
mike martz and that whole deal it was uh
uh
you know another ego guy that
thought he had the right to say what was
going on with a player that had a
serious injury you know and uh didn't
want to understand that
you know
this guy that hasn't missed the down of
football
in six years
uh
since he started in this league or a
practice for that matter
is complaining about something and not
really kind of complaining just kind of
saying hey i don't know i don't feel
right you know should i be out here
right now
you know they rushed me and
they screwed that up during the season
then they put me back in
four months off of back surgery and i
didn't know you know they're in charge
of the whole deal
you know you're in their doctor's care
i've never had a back injury before i
didn't understand what you know that
involved with rehabilitation etc and
then i go back to training camp blow my
back out again because i went to him and
said hey man i don't feel right like the
first couple days of training camp i
said i i thought i was in better shape
right now but i just my leg is way
behind i don't i don't feel good i don't
think this is
i think i need to really kind of
reevaluate my situation here and
maybe rehab a bit stronger right now
because i'm i'm feeling really weak in
certain areas
no no you're fine you had the surgery
it's okay
boom came back into practice okay i'll
keep going you know keep telling me i'm
fine
you know you trust so long and it just
keeps continuing to bite you in the ass
and then you kind of get fed up you know
and at that point then i started
you know continuing my my
uh
admissions to the media and
you know delving some information about
how things were going and people don't
like that you know they don't want to
they don't want critical thinkers they
don't want people to uh step out of line
and uh
you know when it becomes that kind of a
relationship you know you're just a
disposable number after an injury like
that you know so they were able to no
guarantee contracts the nfl
see you later you know cut you
now you're back in the market where you
just signed a multi-million dollar
contract now you're looking at
you know league minimum with a split uh
you know
uh
craziness it moves [ __ ] fast brother
yeah and you know
the bottom line is you have to stay
healthy because they got three guys in
line to fill your [ __ ] thing yeah so
now you have a child you have a big
house you bought that [ __ ] it's more
than staying healthy though it's it's a
lot of politics oh apps are [ __ ]
loose yeah it's more than sticky because
that's what it was for me you know if it
was just things
and it's politics you don't need and you
never knew with that yeah it exists with
stand-up comedy and it's just with
acting
you know this guy has this movie role
you're perfect for it well we think that
paul rudd would be better what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
but it's just there's so many
variables
to make a decision sometimes that yeah
that you don't know at the time oh yeah
and you don't understand yeah i think
that happens in like regular offices too
like oh will you come in this weekend
totally you work for free it's just
it's amazing how
like it's your entire how long have you
been playing football um i didn't i
didn't start playing until i was a
senior in high school oh yeah
yeah
one of those stories
uh but even then you put four years of
college and then what six years in the
nfl uh red shirted so yeah high school
then five of college and then uh
nine
uh technically in the end now when you
get red shirted you still play you still
practice i'm sorry
uh yeah you're just a practice practice
dude yeah yeah you just when you walk
then you rock too oh yeah that's your
game yeah right so you just rock
definitely yeah i mean and if you go to
a good college then you know you're
coming out of high school and you're
running scout team for the big boys you
know you're going against
the first team you know you're coming
straight out of high school that's
that's a i remember this dude from l.a
carson leomedy man this dude massive
and he come around the corner on a on a
trap play man and just
launched me like five yards you know
this dude was 350 big old samoan
polynesian cat man massive
and uh just came around the corner
blazing fast this guy was for as big as
he was unbelievable
and uh you know he was in he ended up a
lot of aztecs going to movies after
college but he ended up in uh armageddon
he got crushed uh in the streets of new
york big old samoan dude i think cooking
out in the beginning in the beginning
beginning with eddie griffin yeah yeah
yeah and uh carson that was him yeah it
just
you know you uh grow up with a certain
set of values
and especially uh from the midwest or
whatever
your dad's a truck driver
you make it to a team you play your
heart out
and they
push you out as soon as something slips
up
something and that's hey listen man now
with 30 30 yeah and all that [ __ ] i did
you know uh the best one of the best
things about the longest yard was i
spent the weekend in a jacuzzi with a
bunch of other guys yeah you got the
stories and bosworth told me that story
and i went upstairs and it [ __ ] with
me for a couple days because you don't
see that these are the things that
people at home don't [ __ ] have a clue
about they don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on you know yeah and they're in
the same they're the same people that
call those sports talk radios and he's a
bum you don't know what the [ __ ] going
on in your personal that's all while
they show you know they show the glitz
and the glamour look at that ballers
show you know it's on tv right now
that's all they want to show you know
they don't want to make a movie about
junior seau
you know
they don't want to do that
now you
when uh your friend contacted me the
cuban guy yeah i'm like why is he
contacting i know kyle kyle should be
hit me up direct
one of the things i looked at that's big
right now and well that was dan that's
daniel yeah that's from uh the
justcoolme.org okay right
that's a you know one of the other
things i'm working on uh
opposed to what you're about to talk
about there but yeah daniel got got in
touch with you and we're doing this all
it's all intertwined yeah i got a lot of
good things and some charities i'm
working with and that revolves a lot
around what that is
you know with all this animes have you
thought about getting into mma
smacking some [ __ ] yeah some
good size to you uh no uh i i i had the
brief thought you know as a wrestler
that was my sport
so i know i'd do really well
but
i should have went to iowa state
actually
because i could have wrestled and played
football
coached by bobby douglas i think he was
bobby douglas you're huge what wait did
you wrestle out in high school um my
senior year i had to wrestle
heavyweights they didn't have a 220
weight pound class but i was i was about
you know 220 my senior year so that was
heavyweight
um but then i went in the i always i
wrestled since i was like seventh grade
and all through high school and uh in
the summers and freestyle programs etc
and then i qualified for the state games
i was like really torn because i wanted
to you know if there was money in
wrestling i would have just committed to
wrestling
but football gave me the scholarship i
had to go to training camp instead of
going to state games and
giving it a shot because i started
finally putting on weight i didn't play
until my senior year of high school so
then i started lifting weights and uh
getting big strong you know and uh i was
i was a
became a really good wrestler and had
some great coaches so
you know all the cars were set there but
uh the mma thing it was uh
uh it's more of you know what's going on
with the brain you know that uh keeps me
from doing that
uh in in two ways in that i know
personally if i'm in there and uh
i know a lot of guys
you know say it but
i wouldn't stop and i would do things
i would i couldn't control myself you
know like it's a fight and
just because of the brain issue you know
it's taken me to a a different place
when that
uh
kicks in
it's it's a it's a whole another world
and you know it's kind of a scary place
so
not really something i like to tap into
too much uh because bad things tend to
happen to other people hold that thought
one second where's tony bennett
is he ready to ride yes he is that's why
i love you lee always thank him
a little something just uh there you go
[ __ ] it yeah man you're an interesting
[ __ ] dude
oh [ __ ] lee
tomorrow about kettlebell class don't
stand next to me corporate [ __ ]
11 o'clock hell yeah i'll be there
it's we you know
you watch these uh football plays i
don't know what year i might go with
ears
with the leather helmets on and they're
blasting themselves and then
you know when i was growing up i saw
people [ __ ] bombard each other you
know i grew up during the pittsburgh
steelers awesome with jack cam and
lambert and mean joe green
you know lester the molester
you're at home watching tv like this is
[ __ ] great
and then years later you don't even know
what the [ __ ] you're thinking about
you're up at two in the morning you're
smoking a joint
and there's a documentary on earl
campbell who's in the [ __ ] wheelchair
yeah you know and uh
i remember sitting there on monday
nights crying in my living room
him running in without a [ __ ] shoe on
yeah they took his [ __ ] shoes at one
time he said that's the police really
yeah it was it was amazing it was just
monday night yep right now
and seeing 40 000 people with little
blue flags
going like this and they were singing
and it's crazy and now you're seeing
this man
in this [ __ ] wheelchair and then
you know
you just hear all these little things
over the years i grew up a football fan
guys i was
i i i took [ __ ] san francisco plus
the one against the dallas cowboys
in 81. i love all that [ __ ] i just don't
now because you know you grow up and you
get involved in other things you don't
have time to
catch up with the teams like you did
when you were in high school and college
i'm still a big uh football fan what do
i understand but
it's hard to like
support them
especially when they're so they take
such strong stances against like uh
steroids and and they take strong
stances against what's going on with
brady but then like they'll sell
these hit these highlight videos of the
greatest hits like the best hits of the
season or whatever and then like you
said you see players
it's all good though you know it's all
good i mean the thing is is that every
player would have
would gladly still to this day
he would be sitting sitting in
wheelchairs proud i walk i have i have
to walk a cane every now and then you
know my body locks up that sciatic nerve
just fires up sometimes and
you know she shuts me down i gotta use a
cane i'm on a cane
you know i'm barely turning 40 this year
and i'm on a cane a lot
just because i'd still like to stay in
shape and
the injuries are you know what they are
and it just puts me down like that
sometimes but i it i walk proud with
that you know that's my that's my badge
of honor you know my uh i've had a cane
before it broke on me but i had it all
stickered up with you know my helmet
stickers you know these this is why i
got this cane and i tell these kids i'm
like don't feel bad for anybody that got
hurt playing football what you should
feel bad for
is that these [ __ ] don't care
to take care of dudes you know we we
have a problem in this country with uh
understanding that
there's a responsibility they parade
around this whole family talk all the
time in sports but then when serious
things happen to people in this supposed
family they just shut them out i mean it
goes you know down to the kids and it's
the worst i mean pop warner right now
you got a handful of kids every year
that die
and or are put in uh spinal situations
why is this and they don't take care of
them
i just visited this kid in mourinho
valley
and he's got a lawsuit against the pop
warner league right now because they
just turned their back and walked away
he made a tackle in a game he was a star
player and
he ended up
getting paralyzed and he sits in a
wheelchair now
and there was no insurance policy for
catastrophic uh injury you know that now
has caused his family to have to move
from long beach to moreno valley and
live in an apartment
you know in mourinho valley that's
you know
and guys like myself and other people
that hear about these stories are the
ones who they're you know going to try
and go and help this kid you know why
aren't these pop warner leagues trying
to help them why isn't the national
football league who has a monopoly on
football and relationships with these
colleges and you know little leagues and
etcetera
to promote their game uh create programs
like they do for everything else to help
take care of these people because at the
end of the day we know the risk we
understand there's risk we i saw dennis
byrd go down
you know when he was playing for the
jets and he came around that corner and
pow and he's down and he's paralyzed
you don't think that's as scary as the
brain injury or death you know we've
known this for a long time but what we
haven't done is taken care of these guys
when they've gotten hurt and the unions
and the league they don't honor
injury situations and disability
benefits i mean that's what's created
all these problems you'd have all these
old guys on canes and in wheelchairs
at all the games with their jerseys on
uh
you know
proud so as a retired player what if you
took care of them like what do you get
now as a retired player for any benefits
anything
uh luckily i got a good lawyer
because that's what it takes uh you know
you don't just leave the game with the
benefits that you deserve you know you
know when you can't play anymore as a
football player it's because you can't
play anymore it's not because you're not
good anymore you know in majority cases
this is because you can't play anymore
because you've received that injury that
has you know took you a step back or you
know for most guys uh you know really
crippled you you know you don't walk
away from this game you [ __ ] away let me
ask you something because this is what's
got me baffled or maybe i'm missing
something
uh where i grew up
kyle
huge football yeah northern new jersey
huge football
i was always a basketball kid early on
and i knew i would play football
eventually but for the most part i got
left back and i sucked so bad that i
focused on basketball and we turned the
team around
seven
to four and three
but i had friends that played football
today i talked to mike ascalese he's the
coach's high school coach's son
uh he left me a message uh he emailed me
a couple days ago and we were going back
and forth on a topic
how come
when i was growing up i didn't hear as m
as
i don't know how to say this late i
didn't hear as much about
concussions
and serious head injuries and football
as i'm hearing now is it the helmet are
we getting stronger are the kids you
know i know those statistics haven't
changed they're i mean they've been
pretty consistent over the years and
decades of how many kids die every year
and
the spinals etc and it's not a question
of gear because you can't make a good
enough helmet to stop it
you know until the government releases
their technology uh you know that
they're using to fly around in their
spaceships we're not going to resolve
the concussionist issue you know until
we can float the brain without causing
uh damage to it because of momentum and
laws of motion
there's there's nothing that can be done
except treatment and protocol and for
too long and why you didn't hear about
it is because it was no big deal you
just got your bell wrong and you know oh
whatever and then all these social
problems that stemmed from it uh you
know that we just kind of pawn off as
getting old or uh
you know
or that was just the game you know
whatever it's uh it's just natural
progression it wasn't it's because of an
injury and we haven't addressed the
injury and that's you know what's lacked
you know they didn't want to acknowledge
it they didn't want to uh
and they went out of their way
furthermore that's why they cost them a
billion dollar plus lawsuit you know uh
at the end of the day so the nfl did get
sued for this oh yeah they settled it
was a it's an open-ended lawsuit right
now it's trying to it's in hanging up
because of a couple appeals
but uh this is a multi-billion dollar
lawsuit they just you know
said okay fine we'll pay it you know
because they there's evidence that they
intentionally hid the damage and the
knowledge that they knew
about concussions the damage that it
caused and what it did
since 96 and they
waited 10 years before
finally not really admitting it because
they'd never they haven't admitted it
you know
it's
still
as a part of the
settlement even
you know it's like you throw a couple
billion multi billions of dollars at
this thing is it's open-ended so who
knows where it's going to go was it
enough i heard a lot of uh criticism
when it happened yeah it wasn't enough
money well it's supposed to be
open-ended but the the structure of the
settlement and who's supposed to get it
is still in question because they're
still trying to say you can't see this
disease until you're dead
which is a bunch of [ __ ] they've got
a bunch of scans out there now that can
show this disease and show it very
clearly i've been a part of two studies
back in boston
that clearly show cte this disease in
the brain
but until there's enough time of study
with these scans that are you know new
and unproven
they they're allowed to just continue to
you know kick the can down the road and
say well we don't know if these players
got this disease
you know i mean you can see it on a
basic mri uh
scan
you know i've had two on my brain or
three
and they're just it's a big blurred mass
when my brain comes up there's you know
an area right in the front of my my
skull and my brain that is just a
dark blurred mass
you know you know all the doctors every
time i get it scanned get all freaked
out and you know
two documented in the nfl which was
quite rare
and uh but knowing what a concussion is
uh you know i've had hundreds you know i
mean over the course of my career i
played 109 games i think uh
and all the training camps etcetera eyes
you know i mean
that's that's a lot of concussions you
know you're earning a [ __ ] job in
training yeah it's exactly you know
you're earning a [ __ ] job it used to
be that way now now it's not you know
it's a it's a year-round deal so they
don't have to uh at least because of a
lot of people fighting you know against
these teams just running their their
ships like you know slave owners man i
mean some of these training camps were
just brutal just i mean killing guys
literally cory stringer
and uh so we had to fight a lot for uh
you know getting these guys to where
they're at today
because we had to go through
the trenches literally i mean it was
louisiana you know thibodeaux louisiana
just 100 and asking a trainer one day
how hot is it man
and he's in the shade and he says
it's 135
and you're like what
oh my god human as [ __ ] oh my god pads
helmets gloves tape
socks shoes you know double pairs of
socks shoes your every time you step
enough sweats coming through the holes
of your shoes the air holes just
you know and sweat is just
filling up out of the holes squishing
out every time you take a step it's like
every guy yeah coaches get life flighted
from the field players getting ambulance
emergency to the hospital body locks you
know full body lock cramp
all day long players left and right we
had ambulances come every day multiple
times taking guys out and they were just
like you know all right we had a trainer
got fired for that because he was
opposed to it and they brought in uh
this guy had been the trainer for
30 years dean kleinschmidt and he was
opposed to the owner bringing the saints
camp back to louisiana
that was kind of the beginning of the
fall you know where i started to see the
writing on the wall like what the [ __ ]
these guys are just all about money man
this is not about the dream and the game
like they talk about you know this is
all about money how disappointing is it
when you find out it's all about the
money really disappointing really
yeah it really does as an athlete you
know because
you fought for that dream so hard you
know
to get to that level
uh is
i mean you're uh i mean one in a million
you know
multi-million one in a billion you know
i mean to be the best especially
to rise to the level of
being recognized uh
as one of the best that's ever you know
that's playing the game that's that's
just it's tough when you see
those types of things filter in you know
and then when it comes your time
to you know for them to acknowledge you
i guess you know and contract situations
et cetera like we talked about
then it you know it's really really
jades you man it's uh
it's a it's a rough pill to swallow you
know because it's not like any other
occupation where you just sat in a
classroom and you did a lot of mental
work this time the other you literally
there's blood sweat and tears you know
that go into this literal people can say
they worked hard to become this or to
become that you know they put their time
in but as a football player
especially back in the day
uh to make it to the national football
league took a tremendous amount of
sacrifice you know i mean you i gave up
college i went to i worked for the
aztecs for five years
because i
i wanted to make it to the national
football league
it was a full-time job and you know and
literal i mean injuries blown out knees
and backs and getting them to you know
go rush into surgery rush into rehab
rush back to the field you know get back
in get back in constantly pushing your
body and the whole time they're telling
you you're two days away you'll be fine
no yeah of course they give you the
awkwardness no they give you all the the
clearance and you know to to go back
kind of what joey was talking about
earlier with how they're getting bigger
i
was the least athletic kid in my school
so just if i'm wrong tell me but it
seems like
a lot more now kids are playing
the sport all year round and go into
camps and and get a lot of more
specialized training so they're probably
having all these injuries
like you said like that kid in pop war
they're probably having like 10 knee
surgeries by the time they get to the
nfl or something oh yeah kids are
getting burnt out these days big time
it's not just football it's every sport
you know i mean these parents today i
was coaching little league uh
and helped coach basketball back in
tennessee when i was living in nashville
and
i mean no matter where it's at now it's
like these parents are just and maybe
that's how it's always been but you know
some of these people just think that
their kids going pro you know and it's
like they keep them from being a kid
that's fine if you think your kid's
going pro but
you know you got to let them be a kid
you know they're just wearing these kids
out man and these parents they as soon
as their kid shows that they're good at
one thing better than you know the
others they just focus on that one thing
and it really sets these kids up i think
for uh
real bad disappointment and failure you
know and is uh you know just not a good
thing psychologically i mean especially
with football because football
is uh it's a whole nother animal you
know it i mean that that literal uh
blood part is is inevitable you know the
brain injury is inevitable we know that
now you know and every parent should
know that you put your kid in football
he's getting brain damage okay
you getting you putting your
five-year-old kid into football right
now you're giving him brain damage okay
as much as you're telling him to do his
homework and get good grades so he can
make it to the next level to play this
game you're you know it's it's
counterproductive to what he's doing you
know so you know
it's uh
people got to start waking up to the
realities of
the human body it has
only so much to give
before it needs time to recover and
people don't let it recover enough
no matter what it is you know so now you
were you retired from st louis
what's the first thing you did
uh well i didn't retire from st louis
they released me and then that put me
back out there i was out of football for
two years
or a full year i was out of a contract
you know five
and then uh made it back to play i
rehabbed my ass off and uh ended up
getting clearance to go back to play and
uh wound up pushing two more years out
of it with the chiefs and uh in kansas
city there and
you know was able to
walk away tall you know
that i went back and made it back i mean
my two best games
most memorable obviously you know my
first game uh when i came in but the
most memorable was my comeback
you know making it back from a major
back injury i mean i lost a bunch of
weight i had to just get the whole rocky
thing you know i'm back in the gym i'm
gonna do it again type of deal
and uh you know just really hunkered
down went to amazing training facilities
and uh worked with
all my old people again you know to get
it back and i made it and you know that
first game back was just unreal
adrenaline
um you know so it was uh it was a good
career you know very i'm glad it went
the way it did because it exposed me to
a lot of the things
that uh i've you know been
working on uh for the past uh
years that i've been retired with
retired player issues uh
and really being vocal about it because
having to go through that uh process of
being the top and then taking all the
way back to the bottom and experiencing
what the average player in the national
football league
experiences
was priceless you know yeah i lost a
bunch of money and
you know
had to play for league minimum all that
stuff and really grind it out earn my
job again you know where
i had just earned it by the way i played
the game you know but now you're injured
and you made a comeback you'll say you
got to fight for your job again now okay
uh when they know you're the guy still
but you know you got to prove it and uh
so fought through all that man and it
was uh
an eye-opening experience you know and
then over that course of time a lot of
things happened
with the retired players and
it was uh
you saw behind the curtain yeah and boom
there we are yeah big time once you see
behind the curtain and yeah
it really affects you kind of wish i
didn't no you never once you see behind
the curtain and you experience it you
live it you go i wish i wouldn't have
seen behind i tell lee
a thousand times
loved comedy until i started getting
paid right
i loved it i loved the excitement of
going out and hustling and eating a
burger or whatever they gave you at the
club and you went home
once it got into money it's where it
sucks comedy just blows yeah you know on
both sides yeah now i have to be
something for sure right
you're following me when i'm a feature i
don't have to be anything i just do 30
minutes and i go home and they give me a
flat [ __ ] feet
well i mean we've talked a lot it seems
like there's a lot of parallels between
sports and and entertainment we talked a
lot about what happened to mitch hedberg
we you and i have talked about that a
lot that they get just kept putting them
out there and then he ended up at the
ends up dead they ended up dead they
didn't care they cared but they didn't
care and i understand it i got a ten
thousand dollar weekend for you yeah
come on let's go yeah and i got three
more behind that
and instead of going you know what
take four months out we just worked
together for a year i know you got a
hundred grand put away take six weeks
off and call me back and i'll have a
whole list but for those six weeks i
want to see you lifting weights mm-hmm
i'll meet you once a week at the improv
yeah you know
that's the hustle man you know that's
the hustle you guys are absolutely right
it is what it is you know i don't i
don't i don't regret one [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no i love [ __ ] no all the things
that happened to me because it's made me
you know who i am in in all its good
ways and bad ways you know but at the
end of the day i i'm i'm i'm going to be
able to and my life is just going to be
able to pass uh
priceless knowledge to my kids you know
and to a lot of other kids out there
that decide to to look into uh who who
was this guy you know what was this
about and uh hopefully at the end of the
day they learned something you know and
uh it was it it's all been a part of the
plan you know i really feel that there's
a there's a whole divinity around it you
know
as well as it's just the world
but
for a lot of reasons you know things
happen man and entertainment is
entertainment though with whatever it is
comedy music i mean i've toured the
country coast to coast two three times
playing music now since you know i've
stayed in this entertainment business
and uh
you know i've i've experienced i knew
exactly what you're talking about with
you know just having a burger you know
and being at the bar with the bartender
after the show you know
you know you know over at the merch
booth and and just shaking hands and
just you know at the end of the day
sitting back on the bus or in the in the
green room and just going wow you know
it was amazing it was fun you know we
tried that jokingly it would work i'd go
back today if my body would allow it i'd
go back to playing football right now
you're knowing everything you know oh
yeah 100 percent league minimum league
minimum
i could do it
physically you know unfortunately i'm
not randy moss so i can't
um apparently he's going to be crazy if
he came back yeah he says he's coming
back man so we'll see it'd be awesome to
see it see
i feel differently when it comes to all
that stuff yeah
i feel that especially if you played
football since the high school level
and then i think after 37
38 without a little help
yeah it's rough it's it's very rough oh
yeah your eyes your uh
eye
you know i've lost a lot nobody really
comes nobody can admit it until
you pass it 10 years i'll tell you what
guys
i remember going to the doctor when i
was a kid and going doc i want glasses
and him going your visions [ __ ] money
i can't give you glasses for years
at the age of 44 guys
i stopped saying
and it got worse and worse all those
concerts i went to i talk about i brag
about judas priest in the 80s and acds
hit the palladium i can't hear if i like
tomorrow when we go to kettlebell class
i can't hear him talking i just nod my
head
because with the air and the [ __ ]
music
and people talking what do you hear
i hear uh crowd noise crowd noise
yeah white noise
yeah once i start to focus it that's
when i have vertigo
you get vertigo yeah i used to get it
all the time it's a [ __ ] horror show
yeah so i just leave it alone now if you
come up to me sometimes and talk to me
and there's street noise and people
talking i'm just nodding at ya
i'm not [ __ ] hearing it yeah because
if i start to focus
i'll [ __ ] pass out
yeah like i get vertigo it's the
weirdest thing so i just leave it alone
i don't [ __ ] hear no more is it
because i played football [ __ ] no now
let's but i tell you how long did you
play
listen i got hit in the head a couple of
times when i was a kid yeah i had a
concussion one time i fell off a
motorcycle solitaire in the hospital
that's all it takes i hit a pipe
uh
what did i do what was my football thing
i didn't play peewee football in north
bergen my mother had a bar in union city
so i played peewee football one year in
north bergen and p in union city then i
went to
jack lambert's football camp jack
offense defense jack hamm jack lambert
wow had a football camp wow and i went
there for a week and i was all jazzed up
about football
and i came back
and you're supposed to be 125
or 135
in those days
125 for sixth grade and seventh grade
and 135 for the eighth grade these are
the really good guys
i think i was at 132
and i was too young to play for the
eighth grade team
so i just focused on basketball my
freshman year
i went to play basketball and they said
listen you got to play football to get
in shape for basketball
because the guy the defense guy is the
head coach of the basketball
so he'll put you on sprint drills and
even though you won't play football he
won't let you play
you'll practice and he'll you'll build a
relationship with him that lasted about
a [ __ ] week
i was a basketball player i didn't want
to get [ __ ] hey man that's a better
choice but you had some head injuries so
it does it contributes to it you know
yeah i was a burglar i got hit with a
head with a pipe yeah it was a burglar
i'll never forget this one particular
night that that
ralphie was here last week oh yeah he
was talking about pt yeah and he was
talking about ptsd yeah and i got a
bunch of [ __ ] emails going what did
ralph get hit in the head with whatever
and i was thinking about in particular
it was like july
of 94.
and i hope you don't mind that tell the
story kyle go ahead i was i was i was
basically broke i was working at
national car rental
washing cars
and checking them in
and i was doing comedy every [ __ ]
night i could
i mean all i wanted was a pain in my
heart to do [ __ ] comedy i was 31
years old
and i would go to lunch and eat every
day
at this place in and out
on from valmont and 28th street because
they made fresh chicken collards not
that [ __ ] you buy at stores
these [ __ ] went and got high
quality chicken collards pounded them
dipped them in egg yolk flour
[ __ ] uh real italian great
every day fresh
and then they let them cool down instead
of [ __ ] with them so when you got there
they were crispy they were still there
no they sold these four guys and one guy
he said it was in and out that they saw
the name i think it was in and out okay
the guy got one of them got caught
selling sending
steroids over from germany long distance
that was the end of the restaurant
business they sold the chain
but my point being i used to meet this
guy there
once a week i always owed him money i
used to buy coke from
and he was a weird spanish dude i mean
like no [ __ ] english
no nothing
and we just happened to bump into each
other on the right afternoon
and he had a chunk of blow
and i gave him like 300 miles and he
gave it to me
and i was supposed to sell it and do
this with it and do that with it and do
this with it
i took that [ __ ] home
i did one line and it was all over i
bolted down the door
i think i ran to the liquor store bought
a six six-pack of fat tire
i [ __ ] got some rolling papers i went
home and i did that whole block of
[ __ ] blow oh man it had to be four or
five grams of blow this is some of the
best blow i ever did in the [ __ ] 90s
i mean i stayed up for a day and a half
whacking off
crawling on the floor
snorting pieces of [ __ ] ceilings
it was horrible i must have taken 82
showers
and then i [ __ ] woke up the next day
and i was hungry and i'll never forget
what i felt like i felt like
i had brain damage like that was the one
time but and i did coke for 27 [ __ ]
years and that night particularly
ran out and i didn't do that was nights
i went 18 19 grams
when i was in my 20s oh nothing about
that [ __ ] yeah when i was in my 20s i
could do
oh a chunk me and this crazy dude from
tennessee
but in my my 30s i was a little
controlled and i did that and i'll never
forget riding a bicycle the next day
jesus and going to eat at this place in
and out it wasn't in and out i forgot
what the [ __ ] name it was it could
have been there and i made the left onto
that with the bicycle
i'll never forget thinking my mind's
never gonna [ __ ] focus
like it took me four days to recover it
wasn't like an alcohol hangover
chemical it was a chemical hangover not
even a chemical it had jolted my central
nervous system this coke was so [ __ ]
yummy
this coke was so [ __ ] good
that till this day things happen and i
go you know what it's from that night
with that blow
oh yeah i got mental [ __ ]
listen when i quit doing coke i was
getting
electric shocks in my spine that my
[ __ ] neck would hurt and i'd have to
[ __ ]
straighten up like that so at any time
at any day this thing was going to short
circuit well same question that kyle
answered like
looking back on it wouldn't you still do
coke
knowing what you know about it yeah
like if you if you have brain damage
from it i mean it's it's a little
different it's a funny story but i mean
to do that much
a little easier to do they show some
[ __ ] half of momo on tv all right my
name is joey diaz i didn't blow for 27
years
now i can't count backwards
really
nobody invites me to new year's parties
oh man
hey well it you know the problem is is
that just uh going back to the brain
injury it's about just protocol and
recovery and we've never addressed the
injury you you never addressed your
injury
from
you know the drug issue or
getting in a motorcycle accident or
playing football or whatever it was
you've never addressed your brain injury
you know i never had the opportunity to
address my brain injury you know we
haven't thought about this enough you
know and we haven't had any on top of
that we haven't had anything to help us
medically we've been we've been given
things that
uh
frankly are are making it worse you know
our country is being overrun with
pharmaceuticals and uh people are being
prescribed things left and right just
freely
like it's candy and and you know these
things are making brain injuries so much
worse you know people with manic
depression and anxiety and bipolar
disorders don't need to be taking these
chemicals they have done a horrible job
at creating these drugs
because all they do is mask as i've been
on them i've been on wellbutrin and
zoloft and depakote
for the past six years and these things
all they have done is masked the issue
and then created a whole another realm
of problems
uh
that
didn't exist
because of the side effects you know
after about five years in on on a psych
med you start to
feel these negative effects you start
reading the bottles and going holy [ __ ]
you know yeah i'm thinking about suicide
more i'm thinking about this more i'm
thinking about i'm way more depressed
you know like this is supposed to be
addressing this it does at certain times
and your levels are right and then you
feel good but after a
good five years into psych med it just
starts praying on your brain on all
those negative ways so are you on that
because of cte or is that just i have
been i have been i was i've been off of
those things for about six months now
but was it was it caused by cte or was
that just you personally um no i think
that there are some personal i guess
inherencies in individuals
but the brain injury itself from what we
understand about what i understand
talking to the best doctors in the world
on this
um
it's that it makes it all those issues
that you might have going on it
exacerbates them like ten a thousand
fold so
if you've got problems if you've got a
giggle problem
you know
and your brain is injured it's gonna
make it it's gonna make it [ __ ] go
to the 10th level
oh it's always you to the side of the
cross and now you're historically
laughing you know
i think that edible's kicking
my anarchy edibles yeah
well speaking of though that's that
that's that that's a great segue because
it leads leads to what you know i'm
trying to do with that i mean you know
we've been given these things to to deal
with these issues
and they've made them you know worse
some better
and uh
you know
i think marijuana can change the game
personally
you know i think marijuana is going to
be the answer to uh uh helping us
continue to be able to play our sports
play football get brain injuries and
recover from them growing up not really
growing up like before i left jersey i
was [ __ ] crazy right cop he standing
at this bar called the midtown lounge
there was a guy that used to come into
an irish guy johnny reed
and he tried to kill himself
it's hilarious
but he [ __ ] up and he he landed in the
garbage dumpster
and he banged his head on the way down
oh no so they did like brain surgery it
was never really the same
check
got a disability check from falling into
the dumpster they sent them like trying
to commit suicide like the ace is
telling him a monthly check yeah he'd
take the check and give it to the
bartender at the midtown lounge tommy
sharples
and then tommy would tell him like by
the [ __ ] 24th listen he got no money
left
but he would be okay
in the mornings you could talk to him
like johnny what's happening nothing i
got to go see this guy about a [ __ ]
job things are [ __ ] bad yeah
everybody's got a job
and then after you have a couple drinks
he was crazy but not violent
and if he did get violent he'd go in the
corner and just throw punches by himself
wait was this the guy you locked in the
bathroom we locked him in the back and
went there at a bar
johnny reed but you're talking about
people taking pills
you know this guy i don't know if he was
on medication
but he drank like a [ __ ] fish
either way that's poison man you're
you're the alcoholic and it's it's
feeling it it's a chemical it's it's
fueling it yeah yeah yeah it's a
chemical it's going into your
bloodstream going through your brain and
eating it away
i'm talking about reef i'm sorry to
interrupt you how does this come into
the picture my brother uh well i just uh
think that you know it's gonna change
the game on how we deal with brain
injury personally to smoke when during
the games after that you don't have to
smoke it you know you know how it is
yeah you're eating it it drops whatever
you know they got it in patches uh
vaporizers you know these types of
things it's you know completely 100
healthy now there's no excuse
for us to continue to say we don't know
enough when our government owns a
medicinal patent on it for a neural
protectant and an anti-inflammatory how
do you know that enough and uh you know
my personal experience it's helped me to
get off all those pharmaceuticals you
know so it's it's undeniable for me and
when you find your strains that really
speak to your body you know what i'm
talking about
uh you know you it puts you
you don't even have to feel high
you know my on on the right strains you
don't even
it just you feel great you feel perfect
you feel normal
and you can tell that that's what all
those after being on psych meds and
painkillers and all those other things
that's all they're trying to do is to
mimic what
i've personally found in certain strains
marijuana you know and the opiates as
well it's all just synthetic versions of
that stuff just push that back a little
bit
talking the
great part the grape there we are there
we go
that's so you said you're you're one of
your partners in this
company is ricky williams yeah ricky and
i have joined together
we've got a couple other partners out of
san diego
michael cendrick is a
big time attorney his dad was ralph
cendrick a
mega super agent back in the day wrapped
all the quarterbacks in the 80s 90s
some early 2000s maybe
but
we're putting together a good group of
football players to really kind of
progress the
uh advancement of medicinal marijuana
you know i mean this is
something that we need as as athletes
you know we've been getting killed by
these pharmaceuticals left and right so
uh you know and some of us have had
these experiences that have stuck with
it and really been on the hunt to to
track this down as a medicine and uh
it's real so you know we're organizing
the guys that are familiar with it and
understand it to get around it and help
hopefully you know push
the needle on it all at all levels
because this is not uh funny anymore
okay people are dying uh daily right now
people are dying while we're talking
from pharmaceutical drugs that they've
been given
uh you know just like nothing you know
they write you that prescription so
easily when it has uh side effects of of
death you know i mean this is this is
serious stuff
marijuana has not killed a soul in the
history of the world you know if it did
you'd be hearing about it a lot and uh
it makes no sense to why
it's not legal
for one in america you know we're
supposed to be free but
medicinally that we continue to make the
excuse that we don't know enough about a
plant that's been around for thousands
of years and used as a medicine that's
that's absurd so obviously when you look
at the history of the game
that the government's created with this
you understand it you understand that
this has some high medicinal value pun
intended that uh uh they don't want us
to understand so
i think it's past time that they can
control that because of social media and
the information era that we're in and
professional athletes notoriously can
move that needle
you know if i can go from
taking a cocktail of pharmaceuticals
that
encompasses you know 10 bottles
as a daily regimen for since 1996 you
know i've been on
uh a myriad of medications unbelievable
amounts of medications um
for 20 plus years and now i i've been
free of those after six months and i
feel better than i felt in
probably 10 years
and dealing with things on a whole
nother level psychologically
uh emotionally etc you know these drugs
were not helping they were
uh they're a facade you know some people
need certain medications to deal with
things you know i'm not going on full
tom cruise but um yeah you have the
option at the you should have the
opportunity yeah exactly that the end of
the day it's absurd and especially in
america that we don't have the option
of cannabis as a medicine and there the
nfl has like i'm pretty sure it's like a
zero tolerance because with josh gordon
and all these yeah they're like years
just being taken away yeah from people
uh their whole livelihood they've been
made to be these criminals you know i
mean how many of these guys that just
get pulled over for having weed and now
they're a thug you know they're from
this now they're oh yeah they were you
know from this area of new orleans or
chicago of course you know or l.a
whatever you know these guys are just
thugs you know and all the dude had was
something that a judge is carrying in
his [ __ ] car home from the courthouse
every [ __ ] day in america so is that
is that why you're
because
as a fan like sometimes when the josh
gordon stuff happens you're like or when
any player happens when they get caught
for stuff like that you're like you're
getting paid millions of dollars why
can't you just just not smoke weed when
you're going to get tested unless you're
for those few years but but what your
your point is is that it actually is not
just for fun if someone
especially in a problem situation like
that okay you have to look at what's
going on why are they doing this all
right this is obviously a medication for
them
they'll prescribe you all these drugs
okay that will do what they think this
does okay right here but at the end of
the day it doesn't and that's why
players do it that's why lawyers do it
doctors do it judges do it presidents of
our own country do it
and people around the world do it
at the highest levels of leadership and
accomplishment and everything else
it's because it works better than
anything else
and at the end of the day it's a
natural element that's not going to kill
you
so as an athlete and you're looking at a
handful of pills
versus what we have today i don't
understand why a player can't be
prescribed this and shouldn't should be
prescribed this after a concussion i
mean this is ridiculous these things
come in little compacts now and here
okay this is going to last you about a
week or two okay go home sit in a dark
room air conditioning on listen to some
zeppelin and [ __ ] chill out you know
for a week and hopefully let this brain
thing calm itself down no we need to get
back on the field as soon as possible
and marijuana's evil you know when it's
proven to
uh
slow the progression of alzheimer's
that's that's a football disease that is
our disease we own that disease right
now there's no other sport in america
that we're in the world that owns
alzheimer's disease and dementia like
football does
and it's
you know
ridiculous that it's not an option and
that the league has a stance on it when
it's something that could be
it should just be you know free as an
american to do i mean while they're
promoting budweiser and every other
alcohol
alcoholic beverage that sends people to
hospitals and to the morgue
after every football game on every
weekend coming up here as the football
season's about to begin all you got to
do is look at the statistics of death on
the freeways from accidents after on
weekends during football season they're
pretty high you know i mean while
they're promoting this it's just
hypocritical that they would
be striking players down uh knowing the
medicinal value for one uh but you know
that it's that mind is still in 1969.
yeah and it will be there for the next
20 years 20 30 years these people are
ridiculous and the things you talk about
they know i mean they know these things
so
and they look at it as uh as a drug
still
you know and i don't think
you always hear all these rumors that
they don't test for thc in the nba
they used to not i think they do now
right they don't no they did not yeah
now i think they do but i don't know how
strict it is uh i know that it they
didn't you know they didn't test for
anything how often do they test you as
an nfl player nfl players only have one
test a year for street drugs so that's
the other thing i mean they you know if
they were really staunch against it then
they should be putting it in the random
drug testing program but they don't they
put it in just as once a year test you
take it everybody knows it's coming
right around training camp and you just
you know get right it's that's why it's
been illegal in the nfl there they have
this weird mentality of wanting i guess
to weed out these guys that
they don't think are you know team guys
or whatever you know for the
organization you know they they're
looking for they're looking for fall
guys instead of football players you
know uh
it's uh it's a real
it's a business
exactly you've got a bunch of business
guys running a [ __ ] sport that they
don't need to be running because it's
bigger than that
it's much bigger than their bankrolls
it's much bigger than their private jets
football is not a
sport like any other you play this game
you make it to that level it's it's
modern day gladiators you know i mean
rugby players as well i mean these are
gladiator sports
mma you know to achieve the greatness of
the uh
mixed martial arts in the ufc
especially for players who are playing
positions like yours like the linemen or
maybe like blind bags
like
rugby players receivers can hit two
until like running backs have like a
three-year career yeah which is pretty
crazy when you say that's the average
length career international football
league what's the offensive lineman uh
the average length of an nfl career is
three and a half years i guess
statistically linemen have longer
careers uh you know because you don't
have to keep your speed as much you know
as these other positions it's skill
positions they called uh you know in the
at the line you can you can lose a step
you know i can come off a bad back
injury and lose a step and still play
online you know whereas you play
receiver or you know db you're getting
burnt you know
so
it's uh
yeah but that doesn't really make sense
because
for receivers you don't get hit every
play
as a lineman or like a linebacker you're
you're just like
like there's a player i forget who what
is it was either mankins or something
i'm a patriots fan and he played with a
torn acl for like half the season right
as like a lineman just put a knee brace
on tape it up
yeah man jack lambert taped a magazine
to his
broken
tibia
ran back out there with a magazine
bracing his broken leg
with duct tape well that's what
adrenaline and stuff that's part of the
other thing that's
always been interesting to me we
why you're playing the game
and why you're in there and knowing
the
the pressure that you're replaced the
next [ __ ] day they got four guys
behind you while you're in the action
you're taking those testosterone shots
you're taking those [ __ ] cortisone
shots i'm sorry yeah painkillers yeah
you're eating the [ __ ] painkillers
because this is what you do guys
this is what the [ __ ] you do yeah
but you didn't know we didn't know
you know you know and you don't know we
we didn't understand the serious nature
you know they started letting guys know
that hey you know shortly after your
career's over with your kidneys are
going to shut down you know you think
down the road when you're thinking
injuries in football you know you just
think you know you don't think it's
going to come so soon
the serious ones i mean you got guys
that are going down right now from all
these medications uh with their kidneys
and livers
uh left and right you know alcohol is a
problem issue too but uh
it's the pharmaceutical drugs that are
just overloading our systems
are you i was wondering that argue was
did anyone ever come to you and say you
have to take this or you have to go out
sooner or is it just what joey said and
you know that if if you don't and you're
out for an extended period of time
that's why they don't have to say it
when you don't have a guaranteed
contract
and there's a guy sitting there ready to
go and you know that you're not going to
get the time to recover from that injury
if you don't go
then you know that's the problem think
about it i just gave you
i just got you out of debt i got you to
give that beautiful [ __ ] girlfriend a
big diamond ring she's knocked up
you're two years in
you're a year away from renewal
you know you had [ __ ] three sacks
you know something happens your shoulder
hurts ain't gonna hurt that much
the guy across from you he's been
[ __ ] on you all season you and i both
know you don't have time to miss two
[ __ ] games this guy has the game of
his life
you're running uphill now it's that
[ __ ] fast what do you do like
do you feel that way with comedy
do you feel that way with comedy
because i'm the type of person i am i
feel that way with everything in life
you got to
i feel that way with everything in life
you gotta go man i remember donna
reverend and i was a basketball guy
and i told you
that in those days
your dad walked around early i walked to
jiu jitsu and the sun was shining on me
a weird way this morning at 9 30 in the
morning i was like wow
this reminds me of an east coast morning
when i would leave the house early just
to go take 300 shots i once heard that
jerry west used to shoot 300 shots
just jump shots every day so i said this
is what i'm gonna do before i even go
play
i'm gonna just shoot 300 [ __ ] jump
shots
and you know this you have to assume
that if you're not practicing that guy
you're going up against practicing yeah
he's in the [ __ ] gym right now doing
jumping jacks you're on the couch
because you're near it's really really
all your life
there's a difference you know with with
injury you know that's the that's the
thin line that they've kind of treaded
in the national football league with uh
players you know this
uh
you need to know the difference between
pain and injury uh has been this the
saying the motto and that's what they
i'm sure still they say that all the
time about today at the end of the
season they're like oh everyone's heard
of this
i mean when you know i mean if the
difference is a player is going to go
no matter what you're not going to have
a guaranteed contract then you're going
to go no matter what okay
if the doctor tells you hey look your
shoulder's torn
you know it might
cause you to as a professional athlete
it would likely cause you to take a step
back and say
do i want to go out there and risk
ripping it completely away from the bone
right now yeah my back injury if i would
have been told hey you got
you got the the makings of a real bad
herniated disc right now it's probably
just bulging you know you might want to
think about taking off because otherwise
it's going to herniate and then it's
going to be a surgery situation for sure
it'll heal in two weeks do what you need
to do that's what they show you
yeah that's what they do
they throw their hippocratic oath out
the window because they're protected by
their collective bargaining agreement
that our [ __ ] fake ass union
negotiates with the national football
league all the time to let these doctors
just run freely away from any recourse
from their advice who's making that
decision is it the doctor does the
general manager tell the doctors
oh yeah at the end of the day they have
a meeting with the doctors and those
people sit in the rooms with the coaches
and the general managers
and the doctors and the doctor will give
his report they'll sit in a boardroom
like this
with people all around and they'll have
the injury report and the doctor will
come in and he'll say this is what i got
and they'll say to him
okay how bad is it
and the doctor goes well
and then that's when it starts to happen
okay they start piecing those injuries
away and saying well okay it's just kind
of a minor tear it's a minor sprain okay
can you tape it up yeah i think we can
get away with that
i think we can do it and these doctors
sit up there and tell these coaches that
yeah we that's how they get hired you
know i mean i've had friends that have
sat in these meetings with these
[ __ ] that are willing to just
wash away any advice to the player and
just give it all
to the team you know i mean they don't
care one bit because they're not paid to
you know and they don't and they know
they can walk away that's the biggest
crime that's been committed is that
these doctors can walk away there's no
vested interest by the team or these
doctors for these players to be healthy
because they can walk away clean from
any bad information given and these
doctors
are like insurance adjusters
they're there to basically cut you off
like they're there to say you know what
you're okay i'm clearing you to go back
on the field
you know what you don't really need to
be in the hospital for three days we're
gonna send you a helmet a day meanwhile
you're not ready to [ __ ] go home and
if you go get a second opinion then you
become a guy who doesn't want to play
with the team
you know if a guy says well that doesn't
feel right to me i'm going to get a
second opinion the answer from your
doctor doesn't seem right this injury it
seems a lot worse and not and i have the
right within the collective borrowing
agreement to go get a second opinion but
when you do that and you're not a you
know a big time guy then you become a
marked man and even if you are a big
time guy you become a mar i became a
marked man you know when i came out here
to la to the back surgeon and he said i
can't believe they put you back out
there after four months off of back
surgery you were back into two a days
and i was like yeah man he's like you
can't even lift your foot up you got
dropped foot so bad that i wouldn't
clear you on a basic physical right now
to go do anything but you know general
rehab
he's a and you know
but those doctors are oh you're good to
go here you know try to touch your toes
and here try to touch your nose okay go
out there you know go play there's no
there's no proper protocol to recovery
from injury at any level
i mean they they got all the tools they
got all the drugs and medications and
rehab equipment and the best masseuses
and chiropractors and therapists and
this and the other but it's all there
just to hurry that process up instead of
to really address
okay you might want to take uh you know
a few or three weeks off here you know
and let's do that before you go back to
the field otherwise you know they'll
never give you that information i mean
they'll vaguely
uh elude to serious situations but
they're never going to stop the player
from going i hate i really hate the
loyalty conversation like for me
personally i'm i'll be loyal to joey
until until the day i die because he's
taking care of me since i've been out
here in l.a and especially in podcasts a
lot of podcasters don't take care of the
producers at all they're lucky if they
get 25 bucks so i'll be loyal to you
till day i die but there's
for especially in sports
how can they even bring up loyalty when
when they'll trade you and that's fine
that's part of the business but if
they're not loyal to the players though
how can they push it back it doesn't
make sense
that's where they lose the players you
know today you realize you're a [ __ ]
piece of meat that's why you have
class-action lawsuits that's why the
game has been trudged through the mud
because they haven't chosen to do the
right thing they haven't chosen to honor
the benefits they set all these things
up and make it look like oh we're we
have all these great programs that sat
in the other and at the end of the day
they don't follow through they don't i
mean no union worth of [ __ ] in america
is going to let an employee leave the
job injured without receiving full
benefits
and
as a nfl football player who's supposed
to have the best union in america you
know they parade it around so heavily
you have to fight against your own union
to get them
to get your to get your benefits
i mean the the boards that they have in
place that make decisions on who gets
disability and who doesn't is uh set up
with guys that aren't even doctors
they're just ex football players that
have personal opinions you know and
roger goodell like what the [ __ ] do you
know about it [ __ ] you played in
college for a minute your daddy was a
politician you held coffee for [ __ ]
pete roselle for i don't know how many
years and sniff jocks around the locker
rooms you think you earned the right to
be where you were at just because of
that and i don't have a
more of a stance than you do in this and
you don't want to sit and try to listen
and understand what's going on that's
why we have all these problems in the
nfl it's why it's looked so ugly and why
we're losing a fan base and all these
parents don't want to put their kids in
everybody's blaming concussions it's
because it's not because of concussion
it's because these parents are sitting
at home going jesus
i don't want my kid to grow up in that
sport these guys are a bunch of [ __ ]
idiots
let me give some shout outs real quick
we'll get to the next thing here
jonathan kobe i love you [ __ ] all
dean franco
marcus lamos thank you anthony torito
and buffalo get it together
jonas presadio happy birthday my main
man malcolm riddle happy birthday
and uh amy another one uh two
love you
go ahead and have some love
it's not even just the medical part of
it i give the shout outs man
gotta give the shout out sure these
people are [ __ ] loyal
damn right you gotta take care of these
[ __ ] listen man at the end of
the day we're all corporate my wife
worked at a corporation ten years one in
there when she was [ __ ] sick
you know i used to talk to her at night
i used to tell her calm down but she's a
[ __ ] american she believes in her job
she gets knocked up we have the kid she
goes back
she asks for a raise
to give her three percent my wife is
furious
she quit
next lady comes along they started at 30
000 more and took away three of her jobs
we live in some [ __ ] weird times with
no loyalty
and at the end of the day you realize
you're a [ __ ] piece of meat
you're a [ __ ] piece of meat
and that's that's the world though you
know i mean that's the real world and
that's what people need to understand
but
and that type of [ __ ] stopped fighting
that type of [ __ ] shouldn't exist in
football man it shouldn't exist in the
nfl it's too great of an accomplishment
you know i mean not to the lesson you
know anybody's accomplishments uh you
know how long they work at companies or
anything like that
it's just to achieve that physical
greatness just uh requires such an
unbelievable dedication that people
don't understand to be in the [ __ ]
nfl
they just see little things and it just
kind of looks easy so most people just
kind of take it for granted the amount
of dedication that goes into
accomplishing that dream to make it to
the nfl is unreal
there's nothing i've i've surfed waves
the size of buildings
i've you know
done anything ever i've been in shark
waters there's
there's
uh nothing that compares to playing the
national football league in that
adrenaline rush and that a sense of
accomplishment i mean uh i mean i've had
kids and you know of course my kids are
unbelievable
uh and it's you know having my wife
everything i've been married 13 years i
just have so many great things but
nothing in the world compares to that
rush it's a nug i'm running out there on
a sunday another level man
on a monday night i do it right now i
run through a brick wall to do that
right now i just i can't run anymore
me too i [ __ ] love to play monday
night football you can get milly science
that'd be crazy how crazy 80 000 people
just just exploding
unreal
what happened to monday night electric
ball
i was telling lee when i was young young
monday night football started at 9 00 pm
in new york city
6 p.m here 9 o'clock that [ __ ] game
started that's late and if the game was
great that game went till [ __ ]
midnight at least 12 30. yeah
and i was telling me a particular game
san diego play when they had that air
core real coaching
and they went back and forth i think it
was them in the minneapolis
minnesota vikings they went back and
forth and they beat them like 54
53 with you know
three minutes left in overtime that's
amazing a hundred points in a football
game on a monday night
monday night as air coreal man lee right
now we would not
father of the passing game 25 years ago
we would not be doing this podcast right
now wouldn't have even been thought like
we would i wouldn't even consider it
because monday nights was an event yeah
from the time i must have been the
seventh grade but it got built up by the
time the 80s hit it was [ __ ] huge
people were having parties in bars or
you could eat or you could drink you
know meatballs
you know this that so you went to the
bar who had the best food some people
had buffets
for monday nights monday nights drink
specials
[ __ ] women were out people were out
doing blow people were smoking dope
monday night you used to say as an
entertainer it became a you couldn't
book shows on monday night no no nothing
nothing with nothing
you didn't get you went out and got so
[ __ ] up for those two hours that you
didn't do comedy after that like i never
i don't i always sit there and go what
the [ __ ]
happened to monday and then thursday
then thursday night even i don't like
the thursday night games
but for a minute there it was huge you
know
whatever night they wanted to pick man
football was became america's sport you
know it really did in 1994 i worked for
a sports betting service in boulder
colorado
and we'd work late
jew hours these guys were shoot
these guys were jews dog they worked
[ __ ] hours so the only day you had
off during football season was
wednesdays
that's it
wednesdays and you had to work starting
friday at seven in the morning you went
to about 7 30 at night
saturday big college day if you'd be if
you could be there at five in the
morning you'd be there till seven at
night
sunday big pro football again seven in
the morning the [ __ ] six o'clock at
night league so monday guess what you
were in that's your biggest day of the
week one day
mondays when people lose eight hundred
dollars
and you gotta get them back and they
call you for a [ __ ] winner
so this is the day you work your ass off
at that day
the guy who owned that place on monday
nights would rent out the bar
every monday would be a different
[ __ ] place
and we could eat for free till
halftime whatever the bar used to eat
like those potatoes you like with bacon
and [ __ ] in the middle like savages
which one like the big potato like the
low debate with him letters yeah like
all that type of [ __ ] but monday nights
in this country were huge there's too
much now well i don't want to say too
much then it went too easy then it went
to espn right
it's still big you know it's not it's
not it's not what it was do they do they
even have them underneath football yeah
yeah they got money they do they have
two games i'm pretty sure don't they
have an early game in the late game
sometimes i think so yeah i mean it's
still a big deal it's just not what it
was you know now it's just super
commercialized and uh all about
your house i mean people are just
staying at home now they're capitalizing
because all the tvs and everything you
know you know people are going out still
watching monday night football they'll
go out to sports bars and stuff but not
like it was no tell me this was there's
as many commercials as there are now
because there's a ton of commercials and
football games
there's only all commercials yeah that's
the beauty of that that's how brilliant
they are they
uh do you know how many minutes
make up an nfl and average nfl football
game of action you know of actual play
how many minutes do you think
well it's a 60-minute clock
for an entire game how many minutes of
actual action do you think there is
in an nfl football game
10 yeah like between 10 and 14
minutes between 10 and 14 minutes
of playtime that's it that's all the
action that's
balled into this experience because
there's so many commercials and the
replays and they've just become the
masters at uh
keeping people's attention with without
providing you know
a consistent game of action you know
it's a literally 12 minutes or something
like that's the average
of an nfl football game of action that
shows how exciting three [ __ ] hours
you're watching this thing and at the
end of the day it's 12 minutes
every play is only a few seconds you
know so
you know me i used to go to people's
houses but once the [ __ ] onion dip
was gone
i gotta go [ __ ] [ __ ]
up that [ __ ]
right out of the container too that
[ __ ] french onion dip that's good
yeah with some ruffles potato chips when
you're oh you've got to have them
64 ounce bottle of coke just [ __ ]
dipping that alone why wouldn't they
legalize marijuana why would they be
promoting you
how much money do you think like if you
could look at it like money spent like i
i used to not want to watch it i lost
i'm still heavy but i lost a lot of
weight i used to not watch a football
game without pizza and wings right like
how much money do you think is made
throughout the whole thing
including like what does it generate
yeah just playing pizza people taking
cabs that's why they control the mediums
people are taking [ __ ] cabs to bars i
was thinking i went to the red sox game
and it's in the middle of the city it
cost like 50 bucks to park so we parked
we went we took the subway in how much
money do there's 81 red sox games every
year how many yeah how much money do you
think the subway makes just those nights
i i don't know about that but i know one
thing when i was in st louis a guy stood
outside he was they did an article on
him he said he was tired and he was
going to quit so he wanted to give up
his ghost here with what he was doing
this guy stood outside cardinal still
bush stadium
only during baseball stadium and asked
everybody that he would come in contact
with they had a dollar and he sat out
there only during baseball season home
games only and he said
on an average he made during every
baseball season like seventy to eighty
thousand dollars
just asking people for a dollar
he drove a drove up bins and
lived in a nice house everything he got
to the point where he was doing it all
the time we were sending you up to
dodger i was just going to say i said i
was going to be loyal to you but i quit
i'm moving back to boston i'm going to
go ask for a dollar
yeah yeah it's crazy the amount of money
that's generated in that business is
unreal merchandise i mean you know merch
selling t-shirts and [ __ ] man i mean
they're selling them for 50 50 bucks
every t-shirt and nfl jerseys 100 bucks
at least that's for a shitty one you
know you don't get a piece of that uh
players get a chunk you know really but
it's all profit shared
so but at the end of the day the players
have to pay for their own medical and
all the other people you know everything
we pay for the players end up paying for
all the benefits at the end of the day
it comes out of the player pools
the league contributes very little money
how much of a pension do you get from
the nfl now how many years do you have
the pensions are [ __ ] they're the worst
football pensions are the worst i don't
know
and you don't get it until you're like
50 50 or 55 or something like that you
know it's like you're probably like 35
when you retire you yeah like the uh
average life expectancy of an nfl
offensive lineman is 55
or 57 or something you know i don't know
what it is it's ridiculous you know they
they've adjusted some of those things
those rules with retirement benefits and
stuff but it's still [ __ ] baseball's got
way better benefits packages uh and
everything i mean
but uh you know they've got a lot of
good things set up now they just don't
like giving
the benefits to people they'll fight
them till the end you know to keep them
from getting their benefits they'll make
they won't accept your 10-inch thick
medical file
over some third-party doctor that is
working for them you know
knowing that he's gonna say that all
these new cognitive issues you're having
didn't stem from football you know
and that's why the loyalty thing doesn't
make sense to me like we just signed
reggie wayne today because the colts
wouldn't resign him
there's there's the colts are still
making money off right to when they
could have signed him to whatever the
patriots signed him and let him be on
the team just for his fifteenth year
yeah peyton manning should have died
occult what the hell that's ridiculous
they you know that's there's no
loyalties at all
in the national football league it is
not for long as the old coach said
and uh that's that's more true than in
any other sport national football league
there's no guaranteed contract for the
players so uh or lifetime medical so
there's no vested interests on behalf of
the teams or doctors anybody else the
agents or whatever it is
it all falls down you know to the player
when i was a kid i was a fan guys
i was a fan i went to baseball games to
football games
basketball
games and i'll tell you
it's not like they reached out to you
and lit your [ __ ] cigarette at these
things
but it just seemed like they weren't
trying to [ __ ] rob you
i went to a thousand basketball games in
master square garden you know how lucky
i was as a kid lee
i didn't feel like i was going to get
robbed
if anything we snuck in there for 10
bucks 15 bucks
[ __ ] like that
when i go to an event now
i feel like i'm getting [ __ ] robbed
and i raped i couldn't even imagine
worse than rob being a fan yeah
you know with the [ __ ] laker games
with the [ __ ]
just regular yeah and there's some
organizations that are giving out dollar
tickets i don't think they're it's never
it's never the good ones it's not in
football in boston the lowest tickets
can be like 20 something for the
bleachers would you pay for those
tickets i got i got i paid like 44 each
and they were they were the ticket price
was 56 but red sox sucked this year but
even still i paid 44 we were sitting
like pretty good seats like kind of
behind home plate 44 dollars per picture
it looked great but we were like in the
seats that were literally there from
like 1930.
but only
44. that's i mean that's
for the front row it's like five six
seven hundred bucks my buddy just tried
to buy some tickets for him and his boy
they're huge saints fans they live out
here in the valley
and they wanted to go see the team in uh
in uh arizona when they play the
cardinals this year
and uh
so he goes to look online for tickets
and the cheapest tickets with the
at least a decent seat was like back in
the corner of the end zone
uh 500 bucks
500. off the company ticket
well that's what i think that isn't that
when like tickets are scarce and they're
people are selling them on ebay and
stuff or
still yeah you've created a system here
that doesn't allow fans to go to the
game you got it's just a party it's a
who's who it's you know it's back to
uh i mean they only let so many tickets
i think back in the day go to
uh you know out in the market to
you know just
bulk purchases like they do now i mean
they allow these companies to come in
and purchase blocks of tickets
that then go on these websites and you
know people are selling them all over we
didn't have social media like we had you
know so now it's just become this
bastardized deal
where it it puts the little man out of
the game so ultimately they can say we
only charge that much but at the end of
the day you set up the system to [ __ ]
the little guy you know they're
guaranteed to sell all those tickets
because they don't once the the stub hub
or whatever buys those tickets they
don't give a [ __ ] if the tickets get
sold yeah you got to wait until the last
minute you know and hopefully get a deal
but you know right from the beginning i
mean it hasn't even started yet the
season they haven't even
they're not ready to go to that game
i don't know when that game is uh how
far out it is
but you know he looked out thought what
he thought was plenty of time to get
tickets and you know there are 500 bucks
i mean months away from this the game
and he's looked to buy him
tickets for him and his kid you know and
it's yeah i get it it's entertainment
and you gotta at the same time
they've priced out real football fans
you know it the game changed i saw it
change over my my career 98 into the
2000s became the shift you know where
the media and the whole
entertainment thing just kind of took
over and uh
it wasn't about the players anymore and
the history of the game and the
loyalties and all these other things it
just became about this
huge party monday night footballs and
all these things that were just going
out of control
and the amount of money that was getting
thrown around and so it just kind of
lost its meaning you know where people
used to go and sit and you know dressed
up and watched the games and now it's
chugging beers and eating popcorn and i
paid 500 [ __ ] bucks for these tickets
you're not going to tell me to shut up
lady type of stuff you know and uh
you know that's what the games turned
into you know a reflection of
the time of no a reflection of the way
they've you know wanted the league to go
and the way that they've created it a
lot of times like a lot of companies
will have suites and stuff and that's
why tickets get so high because these
companies can pay a lot of money and
real fans aren't there like my dad
worked at a seafood place in boston and
they had seats in above home plate right
where the press box is like behind glass
and there's waders and and it's great
stuff
but i hated i love i didn't hate it it
was it was cool to watch the game from
there but my favorite place to watch the
game from is the bleachers sure it's a
bit it's such a different experience and
it's so much fun
it is and it's not anymore you know i
mean it is but it isn't it's just a big
spectacle it's fun to go see the whole
deal just for the experience because
it's so massive now and all the bright
lights and big screen tvs i mean no
dallas cowboy stadium you don't even you
can't even see the field you don't have
to they got a massive screen in the
middle of you know
in the middle of the stadium there
that's as big as the field so uh that's
what it's turned into it's unfortunate
you know
um
as a player it just sucks because you
you
everybody all this is fine and this is
great and all but at the end of the day
you see all this growth you see all this
money and wealth and power and all these
things just growing and you see the guys
that built it and they're down here and
they're in wheelchairs and they're
[ __ ] and they can't their wives can't
take care of them
because
they're a spouse i mean guys have gotten
divorced so that they can get the money
from the nfl to be the primary caretaker
because it can't be a spouse you know
guys that have had alzheimer's dementia
bad situations als situations and the
league in the union doesn't care to
honor their their disabilities and allow
them to you know live a decent life
after that or these little kids you know
that are getting these spinals in these
wheelchairs you know they can't walk
anymore and they just
go away you know go away and if we would
only protect that uh and put a priority
on on honoring those individuals that
sacrificed you know and for the dream
we wouldn't be where we're at with all
the negative talk you know we'd be
praising football still and and wanting
all our kids to play it because
at the end of the day it does teach some
great things
but it gets it's gotten lost uh
completely on the the whole
entertainment uh
aspect of it it's created a monster that
they can't control where all these kids
now it's not about making it to the nfl
to honor those guys that you saw coming
up you know i mean it was it was danny
white tony dorsett
for me you know his the dallas cowboys
and then and then uh watching howie long
i mean just made me want to be like him
you know watching those guys and i'm
sure these young kids today are you know
the same they're watching their favorite
players but because of the
commercialization of it and how the
league doesn't
really
how and the kids they see this uh how
they don't have the players backs and
you know this whole mess that's gone on
these kids today i mean they're showing
up with earrings on there you know i
mean that all kind of started with dion
sanders and then just trickled down you
know and you still have it today with
guys like chris carter that are going to
say
get yourself a fall guy you know they
don't want to hear from guys like me
they will never bring me to the rookie
symposium because i'm going to tell
their players what the [ __ ] they need to
know
they would rather bring guys like that
to the rookie symposium
so they can tell them what they want
them to know and that that is we own you
[ __ ]
so do what we say
and we'll take care of you
if you don't do what we say
and you don't
keep in line and you step out and you
say a few things here you don't act like
you want to go along with this then [ __ ]
you you know and
that at the end of the day is what all
these kids are seeing and that's
corrupted football and
uh it's just uh it's just a big old
entertainment industry now you know all
these kids are out for that money at the
end of the day
like ballers
let's wrap this [ __ ] up here give
talk to our sponsors
that was [ __ ] great man what's up lee
how you feeling you ain't even not as
[ __ ] no
look i can see it in your face you got
no blotches you're looking good the
boston there did you eat pizza no what
you got hot dogs
no just uh legals don't be [ __ ] you
guys need them you need them kettlebells
in here [ __ ]
that'd be fun yeah i'm really liking
that glass
yeah to do at night get microphone you
know [ __ ] you guys are eating enough
edibles you need to burn that [ __ ] off
that's good
i'll [ __ ] you you just
i almost passed out here 10 minutes ago
i swear to god oh yeah i couldn't look
at it no more we're gonna we're gonna me
and ricky we're gonna create a whole
line of uh
nutritional edibles that are going to be
like protein
bars and drinks and shakes and all kinds
of stuff but we're going to put some
good stuff in there and
and
try to get people to use it at the right
times and we believe it's going to be
after a nice workout 22 grams of protein
exactly 150 milligrams of [ __ ]
high-powered
mexican [ __ ] seed briefer 150
milligrams
you're going to need to make one for
joey like 700 milligrams
150 doesn't even
drop in the bucket to you anymore 450 a
fine refined way [ __ ] thc grief of
protein yes the exact amount right
from the from the jungles of brazil and
the pervian nut a specialized nut that
flies in twice a year from the jungle
flies in
they fly the [ __ ] thing in from the
jungles of doing bamba colombia they use
it for energy
when they run out of cocaine they eat
this thing
people will [ __ ] drink those protein
shakes up you make a nice chocolate
espresso chocolate it would make the gym
a nice surprise
shoeing a super duper looper [ __ ]
special
kyle milkshake with peanut butter wheat
germ
[ __ ] almond milk the whole thing
dog with 150 thc milligrams
it's called you ain't going nowhere
protein shake in fact
i get it that's right i'm not going to
say nothing you just cut my commercial
there you go who the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with some [ __ ] novice
from yesterday bill let me give some
shout outs here to my main [ __ ]
on it always [ __ ] keeping me together
you didn't take that stuff to turn
around 180.
you have to blast listen man i've spoken
to three
four people
in two weeks that told me they've flown
they got sick
i fly all the [ __ ] time i used to get
sick all the time
and there's a reason why i don't get
sick anymore it's that [ __ ] honor
that turn around 180. i blast a baby
[ __ ] pill
i blast two [ __ ] those things i put
that powder in the thing and they stir
it up and i drink it with water when i
start traveling more i'll have to get
something can i avoid anything i wipe
the table down with the towelette i wipe
my fingers down i don't touch [ __ ] on
that [ __ ] plane when i come off the
plane there's nothing but a shower in my
future i check i swear to god i don't
[ __ ] around these [ __ ] walk
around after they fly and mingle with
people ain't no england they know
mingling i forgot about that there's
screens now that i was touching the
entire three of them yeah you just went
at the airport
i'll tell you though i i've been off of
pharmaceuticals for six months my family
my wife my kids i've got little ones
they've been sick a couple times i
usually get sick when they get sick
and since i've been off the
pharmaceuticals they've been sick a
couple times and i've been around other
sick people and i've not gotten sick
once i've been on airplanes and i've
been run down and i've been kicking my
ass trying to get myself back in shape
your resistance is tough
and i believe that that uh off i mean i
don't even take an aspirin anymore i
don't take a leave i don't take aspirin
i don't think anything with any
chemicals in it whatsoever anymore and
since having that lifestyle i've been
healthier i think than i've ever been in
my life i mean i'm i'm not getting sick
at all i'm like back to being when i was
a kid with all the growth hormone
pumping through my veins and not getting
sick
i it's been actually quite eye-opening
to rid yourself of pharmaceuticals and
to trust cannabis it's uh
something i think everybody should do
just to give it a shot because for me
it's created a whole nother life for me
take a chance columbus today sucker
throw away the viking listen to kyle
turley damn right stop [ __ ] around
goodall.com
and press in your code ten percent off
your first
listen go to hunter.com let's be honest
with yourselves go to honor.com they got
great supplements every day i get great
[ __ ] reviews from people it all
starts with the alpha brain 100
nootropics 100 money back guarantee they
don't want the [ __ ] product
that's belief that's why i [ __ ] with
these people not only do they have that
they have to have protein
the testosterone booster i can sit here
and [ __ ] you [ __ ] cause i
don't know the chemicals do me a favor
go to honor.com right now
look at all the great line of products
they have i can't help you with the
bodybuilding [ __ ] and kettlebells and
i'll get you ten percent off on the
supplements all right go to honey.com
right now and press in church boom and
get 10 off your first order and if you
like it
send them your credit card number and
get the stay on the program it gets
delivered to your door on a monthly
[ __ ] level you want to put your
credit card out there that's up to you
i'm not forcing you to do no don't
listen to me i'm just telling you you
got options
do they have cbd products what's that on
it do they have any cbd products i think
they're working on it also i'm not
[ __ ] 100 sure well they need to get
on it we're calling out to the podcast
i'll have you i'll connect you with the
guy you call him up you tell him all
your gripes all right that's the [ __ ]
here's the beauty all right your time is
precious and you want to feed your mind
which was what what's best out there for
you and who has the time to sit through
all this nonsense on the [ __ ]
internet so for those of us who want
premium content and don't have time
wasting it there's next issue next issue
is the mobile app that lets you tap
directly into the world's most popular
magazines anytime anywhere using your
phone or your [ __ ] tablet all
right here's what you got to do this is
iconic magazines like people
vogue esquire time and a lot more and
next issue lets you dive deeper
into the story with interactive content
for richer reading experience sign up
for next issue right now you'll get
immediate access to all the top
magazines including back issues and
exclusive
videos and photos all right
i know that lee downloaded it but let me
tell you what they got my favorites are
rolling stone you got runners world you
got self magazine
you got teen vogue if you're a [ __ ]
pedophile you got men's journal i mean
you got everything here l.a doctor plus
you got
lee don't call for around me i got [ __ ]
to do this week [ __ ] plus you got
premium titles
u.s weekly time the new yorker star
sports illustrated and a lot more so do
me a favor right this is what i'm gonna
do for you [ __ ] all right
next issue is offering a free trial
right now go to the next issue dot com
slash joey and again try next issue for
free right now when you go to next issue
dot com slash joey lee talk to these
people about next issue and what you
thought it's great and so what you what
you do is you download you go through
all these magazines and they they have
to ask you for your favorites and then
you you just go and you can have a back
it's not even just like the most recent
issue they have backlogs backlogs
that's a beauty and you download it and
um
and you can it's not even just like the
text like sometimes when you go to
websites it's just like the text of the
article they have like the full magazine
i didn't get any with the uh the extra
video content or anything but i i got
one you get to like scroll through the
stories like you don't flip through all
the pages if you don't want to you can
just like see what the stories are and
they have everything it was great for
the flight especially for the last one
because they didn't have any screens on
the plane you downloaded all of them
before you went on the plane i did but a
lot of plans have wi-fi now all right so
you could download them while you when
you're up in the air yeah there you go
so do me a favor go to next issue.com
right now and press in what are they
pressing joey slowly slash joke
no no i was gonna say capital letters
because sometimes that [ __ ] me up too
and that's the basketball for the free
throw right now so do me a favor go to
next issue dot com slash joey all right
tell him uncle joey sent you as usual
the best e hit the best e-cigarette out
there in the market hit e-cigs right now
five for 50 bucks whether you want the
tobacco the one i'm smoking right now
you're looking at me going joey you look
so [ __ ] international
and it lights up red at the end like a
doctor nobody knows not you can jerk off
a smoke a cigar a little blanket
nobody knows nothing nobody knows
nothing
smoking jerking all right they also have
tobacco they have
helius 6 that have tobacco on them and
24 milligrams 16 8 and 0 if you want to
get the monkey off your back they've
said yeah what's the cigarette version
in cigar what's the zero what's the zero
thing is it no nicotine i heard you guys
watched one of your uh one of the
podcasts you were talking about the zero
yeah just if you like the taste or like
you've got over just
our old friend ralphie may oh yeah he
gave me one of those when it first came
on the market man you won't be driving
two hours if you have guys i barely made
it out i barely made it down from his
house in the hills there to the hotel
that was a rough night
when i got him off the helicopter off
this ship i wasn't there no no no no i
wasn't there for that yeah this was at
his house man
yeah no i can't mess with edibles too
much you just go with joey's church
as long as they're uh strain specific
that's what uh these are these there's
anarchy otherwise not the strainers
anarchy lg
direct from [ __ ] hell yeah
they gave abe lincoln
this is the [ __ ]
this is the [ __ ]
this is just the [ __ ] right here i ate
ravi had a whole carrot cake i ate a a
whole carrot cake listen let me tell you
something it's horrible
these are delicious these brownies from
anarchy edibles yeah the stars are great
the [ __ ] the little baby stars are
great well those big stars are fresh oh
my god rice crispy treats are great but
i'll tell you these little brownies will
put you in [ __ ] jupiter
okay you want to go outside and get a
[ __ ] pogo stick
but you know the great thing is that
that's all you need to have probably one
of your best night's sleep you've ever
had and like why shouldn't anybody be
able to experience that just once to say
let me try this instead of this
chemical concoction that you're giving
me called
somas and
flexural and
uh i watched one of the videos i read i
was in the video
and he said that they they were giving
you
uh arthritis medication that got
recalled for something terrible
everything they've used professional
athletes to market every drug why would
anybody take anything
football players take it the athletes
take it you know that's what kills the
pain that's what they use
because that's what we talk about using
you know because that's what they've
given us and all you got to do is take
one bite of that you'll have to sleep
like a baby
joey doesn't take one bite
hey some people build up a tolerance why
can't you build up a tolerance to some
that ain't gonna kill you or give you
another illness or a disease nobody's
ever died from brownies [ __ ] yeah
nobody nobody goes to the hospital
because they ain't a brownie with
refrain well they go they just it's so
funny like here are these people like i
thought i was gonna have a stroke it's
like some old lady like
if you thought you were gonna have a
stroke you would have died okay you
would have had a heart attack
it obviously doesn't do anything but
just give you a bad trip if you took too
much or you had the wrong strain
these people go
absolutely crazy and trying to demonize
this man it's unreal
totally you're a bad [ __ ] and
then the other life joy huh nailed the
life oh yeah yeah i'm sorry what the
[ __ ] are we doing here we're talking
about the edibles man hold on one second
of edibles you're throwing me off here
nailed the light.com those gummies and
mangoes always coming at you like a
[ __ ] the big black kahuna whether
it's the gumi's hermanos or whether it's
a new white chocolate line they have but
what their specialty is is the [ __ ]
vape the vapor pen they got is top-notch
go to hell what is it
calm
impression one joey is joey diaz and get
20 off your first one it's a 50 [ __ ]
vapor pin you got 40 [ __ ] dollars you
understand what's the name nailed it
life.com tremendous i don't know that
i've tried that one no no that's one
time we don't have none here because we
gave them away to the blind kids over at
the [ __ ] church
y'all met the synagogue playing be the
song
i would love to see like jewish kids
with the paper
with like the little squirrely curls
with me
just shaking their eyes where are you
where are you i smell
they're blind jewish kids
i don't [ __ ] know i didn't say that
did i [ __ ] say that
it does wonders for eyes why are you
putting the kiss at death on me you
never know blind jewish kids i don't
know blind jewish kids around last guy
who had blind kids running with jesus
look what god had
jesus used to walk around like three
little arabs with no eyeballs and [ __ ]
look what happened
nailed
they put the [ __ ] eyeball of death
for them yeah they did and look what
happened to him poor jesus poor [ __ ]
jesus yeah
i love you
my brother baby jesus tell them the name
of the organization
[ __ ] those brownies are good uh
well
you know daniel got me here uh the group
that we're working with justcoolme.org
uh is an effort based around
uh
another a natural element we're
combining all these things you know what
the ultimate goal is to create a center
for nfl football players where we could
sit around i'm sorry he's just eating
another animal eat brownies and uh you
know get our minds right
you know
we're tired of all this man and uh
justcoolme.org
uh was a uh a group started by daniel
martinez and uh he's a nice guy email me
great guy great guy
and he uh
created this foundation unreal
foundation and uh he's kicking ass man
it's it's really hard to find people
to uh do really well
uh with charitable projects and this
guy's out there hustling man
god you like weed because you're a big
man
i know where you're at it's quite cold
it wasn't
just here at a guy who could kill us
hopefully at the end of the day with the
the other group the gridiron cannabis
coalition
we can resolve these issues and uh you
know get the right
levels that can be perfect so you don't
you don't go over
oh
and we can get to the signs of this
thing and resolve some issues we can
keep playing football that's right we
believe in that [ __ ] right here you
know your shoulder hurts have a [ __ ]
t.a.c
hey why not i'll put you in your hotel
room we'll get your little chinese girl
to cover them over rub your feet honor
your benefits and and give your players
the medicine they need why do you keep
finding more brownies yeah he's like
pulling him out of anywhere like
everywhere over here he's got a brownie
you should see his bag when he comes in
here takes like five minutes down
you're going to kettlebell class
tomorrow
11 a.m
i sweat this [ __ ] out yeah right right
i'll start all over again i say you got
to you got to get them those kettlebells
in here
yeah you need a whole cage and a trainer
do you work out when you're high
uh yeah you know nowadays it's so
medicinal that yes because i have to
build up my tolerances uh
uh to a level where because when if you
work out and you work and you train hard
then you sweat a lot then uh you're
bleeding out thc you're bleeding out you
know cbd everything else that's in the
cannabis
uh
plant so it's coming out of your system
you know it doesn't stay in uh like like
other drugs do you can you can rid
yourself of marijuana by going to the
sauna in a day
uh you know it's going to maybe stick
around in your hair but it's going to
get out of your system i mean that guy's
passing drug tests left it right in
college by just drinking a gallon of
water the night that they the night
after they smoked and go hitting the
sauna and get a good workout in you know
just sweat their balls off so
uh
you know
i work out i i
now with certain strains i get uh uh
myself right before i go to the gym and
uh and train because i know i'm going to
be getting it out of my system and i
have to go through that whole process
again to get it back to where it's good
you know there's there's optimal levels
to
this as a medication and if you train
hard and you work out it's gonna you got
you know you then get sobered up real
quick and you're not high anymore you
don't or you're not not necessarily high
you just
certain things start to creep back in
when you got ailments
you got it you got you got uh uh
depression and anxiety and all these
other things that start to weigh in on a
sober mind
you got to medicate man
you got to medicate so now it's a it's a
constant deal you start your voices
like what the [ __ ] is this guy talking
about jesus christ he won't shut up
about
technicalities i just want to get high
oh my god
see i can't do that no more it sucks i i
i passed that level because i'm very
strain specific my my this brain injury
has caused uh everything to become ultra
sensitive
so uh anything caffeine
or chocolate or other things that just
you know spark things in the brain
omega-3s
uh that thin the blood stuff like that
it preys on the brain injury uh in a big
way
and uh so you know
yeah
i think i'm very strain specific
what do you what strain are you looking
at um in the sativas uh i've found jack
carrera and dutch treat are highly
medicinal
um
and then my indica strain is san
fernando valley it's uh in the family
the og kush and
uh
department you know well you know what
and that's a badass indicator lucky
[ __ ] there because it started death
is right from the indica valley that you
want you got the san fernando valley
listen this [ __ ] story that
was invented in the san fernando valley
it's got to be that strain though listen
though yeah you eat a piece of this dog
i'll take a piece home with me because i
can't drive with it
you go home you eat it tonight before
you go nappy no no time yeah you wake up
in the morning you're going to be
jumping up and down like [ __ ] like
[ __ ] love it i don't even know like a
blind jew
like a blind jewish kid like a blind
jewish singing the beatles this is the
[ __ ]
this is the [ __ ] right here this is what
they have to pass on all the locker
rooms anarchy edibles
stars of death no like if you were a
charger player
and you had a medical card could you
smoke weed or no no or or broncos or
seahawks nobody else nobody that's the
other side of this whole [ __ ] thing
that people don't understand that you
can't and the shittiest part is a [ __ ]
what it does
inflammatory after a game you smoke a
few numbers takes your mind off the pain
whatever they don't give a [ __ ] well as
long as you pass that test at the
beginning of the year and you're not you
know you're not gonna you you don't get
arrested for it or get in trouble with
it then you can use it but you know
you you you're not supposed to i mean
it's opposed to you gotta use on the
downloads
[ __ ] pills and say here go home with
that you know instead of you know here
take this vape pen and just go chill out
for a while you know it's ridiculous
all right what we're going to see you
again doing i hope so man i appreciate
that where are you at
riverside no no no i'm talking where can
they find you
gridironcannabis.com all right
check it out
you got a headache you get to this
website he'll send you a [ __ ] join us
some [ __ ] that
forget about it that's what they gave
the vietnam kids we're working on it
we're going to israel we're going to go
talk to that guy over there
yeah
really that's why the flag is going to
escalate
cover a hole in the wall yeah
leave right
just don't tell them you hate hummus if
you eat how much over there just keep it
on the download don't be well you know
his test on you uh israel is progressing
science on marijuana like to
uh
unbelievable levels seeley you go see
i'm prepping you to be a [ __ ] tsar a
weed
you don't even know i'm telling you what
about moving to israel you could talk to
[ __ ] the guys that attic are going to
be and
the special star of death jesus style
like a picture of jesus hanging inside
the middle of the stall and just hanging
and you go to israel and pass those
[ __ ] things out who's better than you
who do you think becomes president of
israel you pass out stars in the middle
of a piece pic jesus hanging who
who
nobody that's who
is a picture of bloody jesus in the
story [ __ ] it i love you [ __ ]
next issue go to next issue dot com
molded slash joey slash joey go to
onit.com
nailed it life
and my mem my main people over there
headeysigs.com
i want to thank kyle turley for coming
up and my little brother
will see you wednesday afternoon or
thursday afternoon
peace
and illegal